you say to people are you in favor of
net yes of course marvelous absolutely
marvelous would you like to pay £1,000
for it well I'm not sure about that
£10,000 for it £20,000 for it let's
carry on with the bidding as soon as you
start putting a cost to it people do not
want to pay and that's why the Prime
Minister has rolled back because some of
the targets were about to bite and once
they begin to bite people say no so what
was it 2026 the Banning of oil boilers
1.7 million f am were going to be
affected by this if they needed a new
boiler they were going to have to go to
a heat pump which was going to cost them
£15,000 and suddenly you have a lot of
MPS saying this is really unfair on my
constituents so yes people say they love
it but people said they loved lock